so you're watching the press preview
taking a first look at sunday's front
pages and tonight we'll check out those
headlines with journalist and author
rachel shabby
and the editor of t-side live ian mcneil
very good evening to both of you we'll
speak in a moment
let's check out those front pages for
you first though here's the observer
contrasts what it calls the two covid
pandemics while britain starts to emerge
from lockdown
world leaders have been warned that
unless they act
soon the virus will overwhelm south
america
asia and africa in the next few weeks
the express reports that the uk economy
is on course for
liftoff as the lockdown continues to
ease and more and more people and
businesses
get back to work the mail lays out the
three crucial
upcoming dates on the path out of
lockdown which it describes
as three giant steps back to normal life
sliding in the mirror claiming an
exclusive with a story that the person
who funded
boris johnson's number 10 flat
refurbishment is a conservative party
donor who's given up to 200 000 pounds
in the past
here's your sunday telegraph reporting
that boris johnson is planning a
multi-billion pound infrastructure
program for scotland to undermine
snp leader nicholas sturgeon and save
the union
scotland on sunday also looks forward to
thursday's election with a new poll
which says voters are split
over the smp's record on education crime
brexit
housing as well the people highlights
the plight of a marvel comics fan who's
appealing for a superhero to come to his
rescue with two hundred thousand pounds
to fund treatment for
leukemia
while the star leads with the possible
outcome of the final episode of tv
police drama line of duty uh that's due
to air
tomorrow jesus mary joseph and the wee
donkey that we don't keep making no
comment
it seems i'm joined tonight by the
journalist and author rachel shabby
and editor of t-side live in neil great
to see you this saturday evening
thanks for being with us uh let's start
shall we with the front of the
observer ian a tory poll lead slashed as
key elections loom
across britain those elections of course
taking place on thursday
and your neck of the woods is going to
be uh
incredibly important isn't it and uh
sakira starmer
was there today uh yes he was i mean
and it's the third time he's been here
um during this election campaign and
you can see how important it is for both
political parties
um this by-election which has been uh
it's been a very long time since uh
voters have gone to the polls
since the general election and obviously
this is being seen as
a huge test for both political parties
but in particular kia starmer with
um it being such a previous labour
stronghold
a red wall seat um but with the
conservatives
seen really as front runners uh given
the other seats that
uh moved to the conservatives in the
general election in this area so
um he's really got a fight on his hands
um and you can see
that with the uh we had pretty patella
here on
um thursday and then rishi soon came the
hardcore on friday that
both parties are really digging in for
the fight to desperately try to uh to
take this seat because
uh really it would uh shift the
narrative
away from the um the the idea if
they were to hold on to it that that um
that the tories were taking these red
wall seats whereas
uh if the conservatives can consolidate
those gains it's really going to be
quite important for them
yeah it's going to be fascinating to
watch isn't it rachel i suppose the big
question is when it comes to hartley
paul
what will happen to those uh voters who
voted for the brexit party in
2019 where are they going to put their
votes this time
well that's right that's the big
question isn't it and i think you know
there's two ways of looking at it aren't
there you could
follow the line um of this uh observer
front page story about
how it seems that finally you know
all the sort of corruption and scandal
stories that have attached themselves to
the conservatives into boris johnson
have finally had an impact on the polls
where the conservative lead
uh slashed with boris johnson's own
personal approval ratings
also taking a dive and with starmer
surprise not seen as corrupt
while boris johnson is i think 42 of the
population according to this poll
say boris johnson is corrupt so on the
one hand
perhaps that will have an impact in
hartley paul but on the other hand
you know i'm not sure how much of an
impact
that labour has made generally
nationally it's been a bit sort of
lacking in substance and inconsequential
generally
and it's worth noting that the candidate
the labor candidate was imposed
by labour hq um on hartley pool
it seems against the wishes of uh the
local constituency party
and uh is a is a remainer um and we're
looking at an
area that you know voted to leave but
also
sees that as a proxy for labor being
disconnected
out of touch um not particularly caring
about um issues that affect the region
so that could have more of an impact
in the end yeah we'll move on we'll move
on in a moment
but ian i'd like to get your thoughts on
what your readers are telling you
what are they saying on the doorstep so
are they saying that uh the
conservatives
have had this boris bounce the
vaccination program going very well
brexit of course has been
uh delivered in a part of the world that
really wanted brexit to happen or
are they consumed by all the sleaze
allegations
um it very much it seems to be the
farmer interestingly so we've been
out in both middlesbrough stockton
and hartlepool this week um engaging
people's views
and it very much seems that people have
made up their minds and
when you when we're asking them about
the sleaze allegations that isn't
something
that is um changing their mind or
as you say a lot of them seem to think
that
the issue of brexit has been sorted out
and if they are
leaning towards the conservatives then
they very much would like to see boris
johnson given a chance that's often the
phrase that we're hearing
because they feel that he's been coming
to government he's been dealt
um the problem of the pandemic to deal
with and still hasn't had chance to move
on
with the agenda that he was elected to
carry out
um whereas um labour voters
see it very much as confirmation of what
they already think of boris johnson
as in someone who is sleazy and can't be
trusted so
it doesn't seem to be making a huge
difference to how people
um are intending to vote which has been
uh quite interesting
um to see because given the the level of
reporting that's been on it
um the um that's how people have
responded
yeah it's going to be fascinating to see
what happens uh isn't it let's move on
uh then rachel scotland on sunday their
front page nicholas sturgeon
their voters split on snp's record in
government uh
another poll uh to talk about um tell us
about this
that's right we've got another poll uh
for scotland on sunday this one's saying
that there um
the perception the negative perception
of the s p
in government is over issues such as
housing
crime um education and brexit
but that there is overall uh
favorable rating for uh their record in
government
there's also a gender skew in an age
excuse so
younger women have much more positive
approval ratings for nicolas sturgeon
and the s p than do older male
voters i think that's probably a split
that we're quite familiar with
nationwide when it comes to progressive
or not progressive
um but it does seem like this week's
election
um the s p will win but the
by how much is the thing that's hanging
in the balance with both
nicolas sturgeon and um the poster
uh john uh curtis saying that it is
really on a knife edge and of course
the size of that win will determine
whether or not
the s p can then say well now we do have
a mandate
to go for a second referendum
they have said that they want to do that
covert permitting by the end of 2023
and with a win they co with this
significant win they could then say to
westminster well look we do have a
mandate for this
so you now get need to give us legal
powers for it to go ahead yeah there is
a sense isn't there that uh the vote
could well be a referendum on a
referendum
let's bring in the sunday telegraph
billions for scots as pm bids to
save the union and then we're seeing
tonight that another poll
uh in the herald is saying the snp could
win
a majority so as rachel says it it is on
a knife edge but clearly
uh the prime minister is is concerned
without a doubt it seems that uh the the
amount of money that is being
projected in the telegraph report is
clearly being seen as something that
that they can try to hopefully sway
voters before on
uh thursday planning to spend billions
on road and rail links
um and beating scottish patients on
english nhs
bids in what telegraph describes as a
desperate elder
offensive side it's clear that the
electoral landscape in scotland is
obviously hugely different to england
where you do have those red wall seats
and
um the uh traditional labor voters
um have moved across to the
conservatives
whereas in scotland that really hasn't
happened and they've moved to
um to the snp how many of those um
voters the conservatives can try to get
back
uh will be interesting to see but like
you say it seems like a referendum on a
referendum in scotland
um and if the snp do
win by a landslide what exactly will
happen then and whether they will push
forward for a referendum
the telegraph talks also about how
lawyers have been asked to
uh sharpen their pens to fight for any
caught attempt by the snp for a
referendum
so uh clearly um the conservatives as a
unionist party will be uh
keen to to win as much as they can in
scotland
yeah uh indeed okay we will uh park the
politics
there for now uh coming up after the
break
could home testing kits replace the need
for self-isolation it's a story on the
front of the sunday telegraph
that's coming up
you ian and rachel are still with us uh
front page
of the observer hopefully they're going
to appear there they are
rachel why don't you kick things off
front page of the observer and two
shockingly different
pictures here the clubbers in liverpool
last night having
a whale of a time on the left without
masks without social distancing taking
part in that
in that test for live events and then on
the right a hospital in delhi
india india the first country to report
more than 400
000 new coronavirus cases in a single
day
it is stark isn't it
it is dark and it's it's it's kind of
grotesque actually the disparity that
we're starting to see and that's what
this observer story is focusing on the
idea that the
agonizing scenes that we're seeing in
india of people
dying on the street and outside
hospitals and car parks being turned
into
crematorium um that there is a risk of
that repeating
in fragile countries across uh africa
asia and south america
um because of this huge divide that's
emerging
between the global north and south that
global north is racing ahead with
vaccinations but
in low-income countries only not
0.3 of people have been vaccinated you
do have to
look at this globally and ask where is
the humanity in all of this
um it does put boris johnson's decision
to slash
uk aid by some four billion in a
particularly brutal light but it also
raises the question of why
have we not waived the patents on
vaccines so that they can
be produced and distributed globally
um india has only been able to uh
vaccinate one percent of its population
the uk
and the eu are still opposed to
those waivers on patents even though
india
and another 100 countries have since
october
been asking for those monopolies to be
broken so that we can
vaccinate the world and you you really
have to ask why
the uk and the eu are still blocking
this
uh ian what are your thoughts on this
well i mean the when you see those
pictures from india is absolutely
heartbreaking
um and i mean it's
it really does suggest that some sort of
coordinated global effort
may ultimately be required i know the uk
and the us have previously stepped up
their efforts to support
uh countries but in a way that we saw
following the financial crisis of a
coordinated global effort
um whether we need to step that up
because really until
we're all safe then sort of no one's
safe really
um we're clearly those pictures from
liverpool
um glad in the heart as we sort of
britain opens up and
we can do more things but clearly we've
been here before where
countries are moving at different speeds
and we've had ourselves in lockdown and
other countries even just a few weeks
ago crowds in india at the cricket
matches
we know how quickly things can turn so i
think
if we can push forward with some sort of
coordinated global effort
um hopefully we can make
the difference that really needs to be
done obviously india is obviously
the world's largest vaccine producer
and it's trying to roll out to
800 million people ultimately it's an
enormous effort
and clearly things are going badly wrong
so um
what other countries can do to help
india really i think needs looking at
yeah um and uh on that theme of uh
of how different um our country is
compared to those poorer countries the
front of the sunday express says end of
a nightmare
the economy is on course for liftoff uh
also this
uh idea of um getting rid of
um self-isolation and and better testing
i mean our testing now is is
a completely different league isn't it
rachel
well what what the government is looking
at now
is rolling out a pilot um to
to see whether um the requirement to
isolate for 10 days
uh if you've found to be in contact with
somebody who has coveted which is
currently the case
whether that can be swapped
for daily lateral flow tests
to show that you actually do not have
covid so there's a pilot that i think i
think is being rolled out
next week and obviously that would be
great
if it worked and that is the case that
it's possible because it will have a
huge impact on
you know whether people can get out and
about and go to work et cetera but we
still have a big unanswered question of
what on earth is happening with testing
trace where did that
37 billion go um you know a
government uh parliamentary committee
earlier this year
i'm sorry that that question is going to
remain unanswered because uh we've got
to uh
head to the break it's the end of the
hour but ian and rachel thank you very
much
indeed ian let's start with you then
front page of the sunday
times it's going to be busy in your neck
of the woods over the next few days
the sunday times headline tour is super
thursday
jitters as poll lead narrows we've got
that by-election up in hartley pool
but the paper is saying that the tour is
now
only one point ahead of labor
um it's going to be fascinating isn't it
to see what happens
it is it's a particularly uh tight race
in hartlepool
um won by labor only by
uh 3 000 votes last time but um
with 10 000 votes going to the brexit
party saw
where those votes will go in the general
in the um by-election will prove crucial
uh obviously reform the uk are standing
uh previously was the brexit party but
it's
it's those votes that i think um will be
interesting to see
if they will be labor
labor support labour supporters who
voted for brexit will go back to labor
or whether they'll make that leap across
to the conservatives
we've seen that happen elsewhere it
happened in the uh general election in
red car
and i think the t-side has been seen as
a test case really for the conservatives
to really try to
push a wholesale generational change in
how
people um see politics in areas of sort
of post-industrial
britain with the announcements of things
like the free port
the bringing of the treasury jobs um
even
in the budget itself team side was name
checked as a place where
um got great innovation and great things
will happen in the economy and as an
area to be supported also
issues such as offshore wind where they
are supporting
um where where new money is coming in
and especially new
um industries are being developed but
whether people will look to that
uh and think um the conservatives are
delivering on their
their promise to level up um will be
interesting to see
and it really will be accessible we have
the mayoral election
uh we have pcc elections we have
hartford council elections the poor
people of hartlepool are voting four
times
um but it really remains to be seen um
i remember when a man in a monkey suit
won in hartlepool so you can't
second-guess what the voters of heart of
paul will necessarily do
rachel it is going to be uh fascinating
isn't it
to see what the people of hartlepool do
decide
because kierstarma is up there this
weekend and he has been saying
every vote has to be earned and he's not
wrong is he
uh no he's not um i don't think anybody
is taking uh hartlepool for granted i
think there's been
quite a few conservative ministers
visiting the area as well and you know i
think
ian asked that crucial question of what
will happen to those voters who voted
brexit
for the brexit party um and and now
their votes are to play for
um sometimes that can be a sort of
conveyor
belt delivery system taking labour
voters to
the tory party we've seen that happen in
the past um
and i suppose the question is how
to what degree all the sort of
corruption
and scandal stories we've had about
the conservatives in the last few weeks
um have actually made an impact
now the polling uh suggests that it
is getting through to people the
observer is leading with an opinion
poll about how the conservatives have
lost their
um their lead is dropping as well and
they've also got
uh figures that suggest that 43
sorry 42 apologies of the population
think boris johnson is corrupt and
uh stammer has much more favorable
approval ratings when it comes to
issues of trust and being seen as honest
uh but whether that actually makes a
difference
when it comes to voting that's still the
question
yeah it is and let's ask that question
to ian then because the front of the
sunday mirror ian
uh boris's 58 000 pound wallpaper boss
is a tory donut you know the sleaze
allegations are still
all over the front pages but what are
people telling you
um in your part of the world you know
when you when you speak to your
to to to your readers do they say yes we
are
very concerned about these sleaze
allegations or do they say actually the
boris bounce is working you know
brexit has been delivered as we wanted
and also the vaccine is being delivered
it's very much a case of um it sort of
entrenching people's existing opinions
of what they think about boris so if
they already
are a conservative supporter or they are
minded to support
uh boris johnson then uh these
allegations often
they see as um
[Music]
a lot of tittle tattle really um however
the there's a another side where
if people don't like boris johnson he
very much confirms their opinion that he
is someone who will
uh play fast and loose uh to suit
himself
and what it doesn't seem to be doing is
is really changing opinions but more
hardening them
um so um it's i don't think it's going
to have
a huge impact although it's been
interesting
it is being talked about more and you
had the issue
to do with green cell which was clearly
a highly complex
lobbying story to do with financing
whereas this is something much more
tangible that people can
uh they can understand about who pays
for his flat to the state facebook flat
does he pays for the flat to the donor
peso flat
all the things to do with the wallpaper
and um
those sorts of details people can get a
grasp on and can have an opinion on so
um i guess it just fully remains to be
seen doesn't it on
um on thursday as to really how much of
an impact it's going to have
yeah you're right we should get that uh
result from the by-election in the early
hours of uh
friday morning let's move on then rachel
front page of the mail
on sunday uh three giant steps back to
normal life
may the 17th uh june the 21st and then
this week
as well i mean it does seem doesn't it
as if we are
finally coming out the other side of
this uh this terrible time we've been
through
absolutely it does and it's great but
it's interesting at the same time that
both the mail on sunday and the express
have gone with these sort of
cheerleadery um we're going back to
normal stories when you might think
uh that the continuing saga
of tory corruption um might
still be worthy of front pages uh but of
course we all we all welcome
um the easing of lockdown um
i've been enjoying uh sitting outside in
the absolute
unreasonably cold weather with a drink
as much as
everyone else and i much look forward to
um
further restrictions being eased um
all these are uh contingent on
you know the the criteria being made met
to ease but it does seem like we are we
are heading in a
in a very good direction yeah near the
front of the sunday express
as rachel mentioned their end of the
nightmare question mark economy on
course for liftoff
hancock backs plan to get people going
to work and living their
lives uh it's been tough on everyone
hasn't it um
in your part of the world in the
northeast um people will be
will be looking forward to getting back
their freedom as much as anywhere else
absolutely we've seen that very much
this uh last
few weeks when uh the pub gardens have
been really packed whatever the weather
uh where people have been able to get
out going to the gym or going shopping
on just those returns to normal life
when you're out about you can see the
traffic returning to normal
and it's just hopefully moving to
those next phases and we won't be blown
off course by
any uh any changes i think that the main
fear is
if a new variant appears the vaccine
program seems to be
uh going smoothly hopefully moving into
people in their 30s
very shortly um and
if it keeps progressing in the same
direction then yeah
that sort of return to normal life and
that relief that we can all have
really a move from just existing to
living that's how it very much feels in
this area where people are
really getting back on with their lives
it was interesting reading today rachel
that one
uh boss of a of a major pub chain uh in
britain
saying that with patients uh admitted to
hospital and deaths falling faster than
have been predicted and
there being zero chance now of the nhs
being overwhelmed isn't it time to
to bring forward some of these dates
yeah you hear that um you hear that
and certainly um in scotland i think
there are
demands around the same theme coming
from um
pubs and you know sort of ants venues as
well entertainment venues
and i think there are quite big
disparities still
um nationwide so there are some areas
with very very low infection rates
and so it does raise the question of
whether we should all be
you know looking at the same sort of
restrictions and the same
you know the same pace but that also
raises
a uh you know parallel concern which is
are we going to see areas that have been
suffering disproportionately throughout
so in particular
the northeast and northwest the midlands
some
parts of london you know places like
newham spring to mind
are we going to see them just stuck
with um bad infection rates and still
struggling
um while other parts of the country do
start to
see the benefits of the low infection
and the easing of restrictions
yeah and let's just finish this um uh
this part with that question ian i mean
do you feel that in the northeast there
has been a
a covid divide do you feel that your
your readers
uh get that sense
oh i think so yes you've clearly seen
throughout this that there have been
areas where there have been uh
particular hot spots for infections
and this has been one of them those
factors that feed into that
are issues to do with poverty and
housing
uh we have one of the highest proportion
of key workers anywhere in this country
because you have people working in uh
industry in
social care in the health service
um and that's clearly had an effect on
the high
infection rates we've had which is also
therefore
meant that we've been in uh higher tiers
uh faced higher restrictions as a result
of that
um and those health inequalities that
were
here before covid have been exacerbated
and
really this should give us an
opportunity to look at those health
inequalities
as we come out of covid to try to tackle
some of those because
if and when the next pandemic comes then
clearly we'll be in exactly the same
situation and those are things
really you know political leaders need
to to look at addressing
okay stay where you are because coming
up the nhs plan to offer secondary
school pupils
a single coronavirus vaccine will be
discussing that story
after the break
hello again ian rachel still with us
we're looking at the front page of the
observer
next rachel two very different pictures
on the front page uh scenes from
liverpool
this weekend those clubbers all out
enjoying themselves without masks
without social distancing
in that trial for when things really
open up and then on the right
uh a picture inside a hospital in delhi
where things
couldn't be uh much worse uh and it's a
real juxtaposition isn't it
yeah absolutely it couldn't be more
stark the disparity and you have to
wonder
you know globally where is the humanity
um
in our approach to this pandemic on an
international level that we've allowed
such
gross inequal inequalities in in outcome
and suffering to have evolved in this
way and the observer is reporting that
the
absolutely agonizing scenes that we've
seen unfold
in india um could very well repeat
themselves
in other low-income countries
particularly in
africa asia and south america because
um as the global north or the developed
world
uh continues the pace with vaccine
rollout
there is still very little access to
vaccine
in other parts of the world it's still
something like 0.2 percent
of um low-income populations
have had access to the vaccine and
you know this does raise the question
immediately of patents
and it was back in october when india
and a hundred
other countries uh were asking
um the wto to drop the international
patents on vaccines because that would
allow
countries that currently aren't able to
to actually start producing and rolling
out vaccines it is pretty appalling that
that is still
hasn't happened and even worse that the
uk is
one of the countries that is still
blocking any possibility of that
happening
uh in a quick thought on this before we
move on
just uh clearly it's absolutely
heartbreaking the scenes that
we're seeing um and really if we can
look at delivering a global coordinated
effort
um which we haven't seen really in this
pandemic yet
but clearly what affects other countries
ultimately will
come back to affect us as well so not
only
in an altruistic um gesture do we need
to help other countries but clearly it's
also in our own self-interests as well
um so yes i think that's uh that's what
yeah i'm just staying with you ian
i want to bring the sunday times quickly
because uh again you know the contrast
is is stark but the nhs is drawing up
plans
to vaccinate school children probably
with that with a single jab which would
make sense
yeah that's right the um the sunday
times leads with um the health officials
are drawing up plans to offer the the
fighter vaccine to secondary school
pupils from
uh september the the paper says it's uh
seen planning
documents to do with this uh it still
feels like this is this is early days
but
uh interestingly that they're looking at
a rollout in schools later this year
i think um what you would want to see
from this is
uh really coordinated planning on
delivering the rollout with the vaccine
if they are
delivering to children what we saw in
this area
and spoke to head teachers when schools
did return and testing was
put in place was that they were given
very little notice
and really had to plan a major testing
um
scenario from scratch and if the more
notice that schools can be given to
um to plan for this then clearly the
better
okay and finally uh rachel let's just uh
quickly look at this story in the mail
on sunday
um uh it's been a real problem this
hasn't it dog napping we know that uh
people wanting puppies his sword
as a result of uh lockdown and the like
but so has um
has crime around that and there's a
picture there of a of a dog that was uh
stolen from a 66 year old man who was
assaulted from behind by
two men who made off with his pet i mean
it's horrific
yeah it really is awful as you say lots
of people have been getting
uh dogs during the pandemic because they
are such good you know companions
in lockdown but that has also meant that
the cost
the price of dogs and puppies has
spiraled so
um some can go for some of the popular
breeds can go for four thousand pounds
which is
four times the pre um
covered uh prices and this has
created a sort of market for
theft dog thefts which have become quite
a problem in the country
and with um staffordshire bull terriers
apparently being
um amongst the ones most um eyed up
uh by the new task force being brought
in to try and uh tackle it
uh we're gonna have to leave it there
but ian and rachel it's been a pleasure
thank you very much indeed and
enjoy the rest of the bank holiday
weekend and you're drinking outside
rachel for the next few days anyway
all right all the way